I was in two different institutions  scary place I was actually 12 when I got  admitted there and then I spent my 13th  and 14th birthday there why were you  there because your dad said you  shouldn't have been there you know I  came to the conclusion that everybody  has their own agenda you know my mom had  her own agenda I don't know exactly what  that was but my agenda was to make it  out on top of that tough spot your mom  said Colin has special needs there's a  fairly fluid diagnosis of what those  needs are this has been a struggle we've  had for a very long time and it's one  I've dealt with on my own I felt very  alone in this by the same token it's not  something that has only impacted me or  him our entire family has been impacted  when you hear that what do you think  it's unfortunate that that's how my mom  you know  phrased me as a person you know I don't  see those things and I don't think  anybody else sees those things